wer das böllerverbot gestern das kam
tatsächlich überraschend und so nebenher
es war nicht der einzige beschluss jan
wir schauen mal auf die weiteren detail
ist dieses corona gipfels hier sehen wir
das eben restaurants theater kinos nur
noch für geimpfte und genesene geöffnet
sind ja zweig im einzelhandel außer in
supermärkten maximal noch 10.000
personen bei großveranstaltungen und die
impfpflicht die kommt eben erst pfleger
und dann für alle das sind tatsächlich
harte maßnahmen große einschränkungen
vor allem eben für ungeimpfte wird das
leben jetzt deutlich schwieriger absolut
die ungeimpften die ihr leben auf jeden
fall ein retro winter das ist genau das
gleiche was wir vor einem jahr schon
hatten uns für die geimpften würde es
aber nicht viel besser also wenn wir
jetzt auch sehen incidents gebieten mit
einem wert von über 350 dass man auch
dort also wir haben es gerade schon mal
angesprochen auch nur noch mit maximal
50 personen zusammenkommen darf man
bekommt als geimpfte jetzt die pflicht
auch zu prüfen beispielsweise zu hause
wenn man einlädt also sind die gäste die
man zu hause empfängt sind die
familienmitglieder die freunde sind die
eigentlich geimpft oder sind die nicht
geimpft und wenn sie nicht geimpft sind
dann gibt es da auch eine extreme
begrenzung also es ist quasi so als wenn
jeder von uns jetzt zu einem im
controletti werden muss und da mutet der
staat natürlich den bürgern etwas zu was
eigentlich gar nicht in seinem
kompetenzbereich liegt und was auch den
auf der auftrag der bürger überhaupt
nicht ist also selbst zu kontrollieren
darf ich eigentlich meine wohnung lassen
weil du den im schein a und b und c hast
oder darf ich nicht das geht den staat
im prinzip überhaupt nichts an da ist es
auch gerade angesprochen im interview
dass man gar nicht weiß wie lange diese
maßnahmen gelten und da stelle ich mir
als bürger schon wieder furchtbar vor
dass man nicht weiß wie lange muss ich
das jetzt wieder durch halb man hat
wieder keine perspektive in den voran
gegangenen papiere nach einem corona
gipfel stand immer drin dass diese
maßnahmen gelten bis also meistens vier
wochen und dann bis bis zum nächsten
gipfel in der regel war da auch schon
ein datum fixiert das sehen wir diesmal
nicht und das mag jetzt einer wissen
aufgeregtheit geschuldet seien aufgrund
eines regierungswechsels der ansteht
glaube ich aber nicht mutmaßlich ist das
hier ganz bewusst weggelassen worden und
dann ist die große frage wie deine
gelten diese maßnahmen einig gelten die
nur bis silvester oder gelten die
eigentlich perspektivisch bis weit ins
neue jahr also es geht darum druck auf
ungeimpfte zu machen der noch regierende
bürgermeister von berlin michael müller
hat das auch noch mal gesagt dass eben
eine minderheit und da sind ja die
umgehung
große probleme für eine mehrheit macht
die geimpften rund 70 prozent der
deutschen sind inzwischen doppelt
geimpft deshalb wird das leben für die
ungeimpften eingeschränkt werden und
natürlich haben wir auch mal unter
ungeimpften gefragt wie das denn jetzt
so sehen
ich finde es ist eine diktatur
inzwischen
und ich finde ich leichte widerstand
indem ich mir solange die freiheit
erhalte
um möglichst hier gut durchzukommen also
finde ich eigentlich ganz schrecklich
man fühlt sich irgendwie in die ddr
zurück zurück versetzt was sagen sie zu
den neuen bestimmungen dass ungeimpfte
hierzu reglementiert werden also ich bin
umgeben hat er ein sehr sehr schönes
leben und wenn wir stark dort ruft dann
bin ich bereit und freue mich ihm zu
begegnen
ich habe nicht an sich gegen eine
impfung
man soll es aber wirklich jedem frei
stellt das ist eine totale menschen
spaltung
das hat nichts mehr mit menschenrechts
zu tun ob es folgen schafften familien
sind alles trennt sich nur aufgrund
corona es gibt kein anderes thema mehr
und die verschärfungen die bringen auch
einfach nicht zwei- und
sehr diverse meinungen die einen sagen
eben jahr bin ich völlig dafür die
anderen ein ist es eine
freiheitseinschränkung heute morgen habe
ich erst gehört 71 prozent der deutschen
befürworten die impfpflicht tatsächlich
jetzt was seine einschätzung also ich
kann überhaupt nicht verstehen wenn ich
diese beiträge jetzt gesehen habe dass
man sich nicht impfen lassen kann ich
halte auch die argumente die da gebracht
werden für ehrlich gesagt an den haaren
herbeigezogen und das auch noch mal um
das einzuordnen deutschland ist keine
diktatur man kann nicht vielen dingen
abrechnen und mit vielen dingen
zufrieden sein aber von einer diktatur
sind wir glaube ich sehr weit entfernt
dass nur einmal glaube ich muss man
einmal voranstellen er ganz klar ist es
gibt eine muss diese ein freies land und
natürlich gibt es da auch ein rechtes
jedes einzelnen zu sagen ich möchte mich
impfen lassen kann ich auch gut
verstehen deswegen halte ich war eine
impfpflicht auch für sehr zweifelhaft
aber ich glaube was wir schon
diskutieren sollten ist die frage
inwieweit ungeimpfte an kosten beteiligt
werden die sie verursachen absolut der
ist ja nicht so dass man als ungeimpfte
hier einfach durchs land gehen kann und
sagen kann wie es belege ich hier mal
das intensiv bett und da verursachen
kosten wir haben hohe kosten wir sehen
das auch wenn wenn der handel jetzt
runter gefahren wird auf zweig und da
ist es schon eine frage oder debatte die
kommen muss was abi beteiligen sich
ungeimpfte an den ursachen oder an den
folgen die sie verursachen ein beispiel
auf der autobahn gibt es kein tempolimit
aber es bedeutet trotzdem nicht dass ich
fahren kann wie ich will ich kann so
schnell fahren wie ich will aber wenn
ich einen unfall verursache muss ich für
die kosten aufkommen und
ähnlich glaube ich kann man das
übertragen auch wenn das beispiel ein
kleines bisschen hängen aber ähnlich
übertragen auf das thema ungeimpfte
können gerne ungeimpft bleiben müssen
sich aber der konsequenzen bewusst sein